[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous video we had stopped at
this point in our solution of the pin
pinned beam under axial load
and i suspect that some of you may be
wondering
as to as to the question
whether we had actually achieved our
goal of
finding the critical load because as i
had mentioned in the previous video
uh we our goal was twofold uh first of
all we wanted to find the critical load
and then to find the deflection so
this particular video will be about
finding the deflection but i just want
to go back and
uh and clarify that the
the step that we had found at the end
this particular expression
that is actually giving us a critical
load not because we have
we have managed to express this as a
ratio of p by p
euler but because we have we have now a
recipe
of finding out k and k remember is
nothing but sine alpha by 2
so our k is equal to sine alpha by 2
and please don't forget that we are also
working under the
under the condition that alpha is
greater than 0 which is why at s equal
to l we had taken theta is equal to
minus
alpha to denote that it is indeed a
negative angle
okay so what what i want to emphasize
here is that
given a particular value of p as i had
mentioned earlier
we are able to find out the value of k
but how does that tell us that p
is the critical load well you see
if indeed you are able to find out
a value of k and correspondingly a value
of
alpha greater than zero then it means
that your beam that our beam or rod
has indeed buckled okay the fact the
very fact that we are able to find out
a solution uh
a solution which is telling us that we
do have a non-zero value
of alpha present here a non-zero value
of theta equal to alpha present here at
s equal to zero and correspondingly
theta equal to minus alpha at s equal to
l
it basically tells us that uh the beam
has buckled
so it means that the value of p that is
that has been given that
is a a value of p which is
uh which is uh causing buckling
now does that mean that
there will be possible values of p for
which this thing
is not going to give us any correct
solution for
k and in fact that is so okay so if you
take
this value of p which is substantially
lower this p
euler suppose okay then you will find
out
that you will not get up not get
solutions for
k by trying to solve this thing this
entire equation you will not get
solutions
for k such that this thing this alpha is
uh greater than zero
okay so that is going to indicate to us
that
for that for such a value of p it is not
buckling
okay so that with this concept out of
the way let us proceed towards the
actual
um steps which will uh
give us some idea about the deflection
and this is very
important uh because as we have seen
in the earlier approximate theory that
was unable to give us
any estimate about the deflection we had
to stop at the point where
uh where we only found out the critical
load
okay so what we are going to do is go
back to this equation
we are going to go back to this very
first
equation that we were dealing with e i d
square theta
d s square plus e sine
theta equal to zero and now our
motivation
is to look at uh is to find a way for
uh to figure out the deflection so first
of all you note
that uh you note
that sine theta
as we have denoted earlier the sine
theta is equal to
dw ds okay so
if we if we just if we just substitute
back here
in this equation this is e i d square
theta d
s square plus
p d w d s equal to zero
and this thing is yeah if we if we
integrate it
uh it once we are going to get e i
d theta d s plus p
w is equal to some constant
okay so previously all we have already
used the constant c so maybe we can take
this as maybe some
c okay
it doesn't matter it's just a constant
okay so
the the condition that we are going to
use now
is that at s equal to zero we have
already seen
uh
we already found
that
e i d theta d s
is equal to 0 and this followed from the
from the understanding
that at s equal to zero theta is not
specified so from the boundary condition
that either e i d theta d is equal to
zero
or theta uh is specified because theta
is not specified at s equal to zero we
had to conclude that e i d theta t
is equal to zero all right the other
condition we also have is that at s
equal to 0 w is equal to 0 because
at s equal to 0 we have a pinned end so
also we have
at s equal to l and which means
basically that the deflection w is equal
to zero
okay so if we substitute these
this e i d theta d s equal to zero here
and w equal to zero
what we obtain is that c two is equal to
zero
which means that
or maybe i can just go to the next stage
here
which basically means that e
i d theta d s
plus p w that is going to be equal to 0
because
that constant we have just found out
that c 2 is equal to
0 now
our motivation here or our objective
here is to find out
w so let's see if we can do that this is
w is equal to minus e i by p d
theta d s now we have already
in our hand an expression for d theta d
s if we just look back a few slides
you see here we do have an expression
here
this is d theta d s uh in this
particular form
uh so
uh let me try to let me just uh
or maybe i'll just repeat the i'll just
write it again
okay so
minus ei by p is here and
uh what i have for d theta d s
from earlier is
just take a look here
there is a minus here this 2 the square
root of 2 and this square root of 2
that gives me a 2 outside the square
root and then i have a square root of p
by e i
okay so
if i just copy this thing
i have to modify this anyway
all right so you see what we're going to
get from here
uh please note that this thing is going
to come with a plus
because there was a minus sign here so
ultimately what we're getting here is a
twice
and that twice is because the square
root of 2 multiplied by this square root
of 2
and then square root of e i
by p and then
square root of sine square alpha by 2
minus
sine square theta by 2.
all right which means that i can write
this
as e i by p
and you please note that this sine alpha
by 2 is just k so this is k
square minus
i can of course write this sine theta by
2 also in terms of
the k and the phi but i can just keep it
like this
okay so you see we are at a stage
where we can say
that we have complete knowledge about
the w why is that
it is because you see this p is given to
us
okay there is no problem there the theta
also we have complete information about
it because theta is supposed to go
from alpha to minus alpha so
uh as theta
goes from
alpha to minus alpha
to zero
we can find the
corresponding values
of w and please note that when i say
that theta goes from alpha to minus
alpha
this alpha here it is something very
much known to us
because in the previous step of our
solution procedure
we had found out the value of k which
mean which means that we have
indeed found out the value of alpha okay
so given a value of
p once once you once you start out with
the value of p
you first find out the value of alpha
and then you
then you come to this formula for the w
and then
just go from
theta equal to alpha to the minus alpha
and then you will be able to find out
the corresponding values of w
which is nothing but the deflection so
now you have in your hand
a complete recipe for finding the
deflection given a
load and this is something i emphasize
again was
uh was not present in our earlier
approximate theory
when we were when we were making
approximations about the curvature
uh of the of the beam as well as the
shortening of the beam so on that note
uh we
are at uh at an end of our discussion of
the solution
of this elastic problem uh
and it'll be interesting to see uh how
this
solution is actually implemented uh in
symbolic python
uh so i'll see if i can make a video
about that but
with this we are more or less at an end
of our chapter on uh
beam theory uh involving both the
bending and buckling there can be
so many other um discussions
possible but in the interest of time and
the scope
that our course allows us
i'll have to end it here and the next
chapter will be
on classical plate theory but i'll try
to see if i can make a video
uh using the jupiter notebook for the
solution
but to actually illustrate the solution
procedure for this
elastica problem all right on that note
thank you very much
you